let's talk about taylor lorenz
so we got the story from the washington
post how the biden administration let
right-wing attacks derail its
disinformation efforts i don't
understand why the washington post
doesn't label this stuff opinion and i
don't understand why newsguard gives
them a 100 of 100
when they don't label opinion
in it she says right here that this
information has emerged as an urgent and
important issue important to whom that's
your opinion hey why don't you put an
opinion on this people see this stuff
and they think it's facts it is not it
is taylor loren's opinion on what
happened so anyway in the article she
falsely claims it was right-wing
disinformation that derailed it when
bill maher on his show came out and said
this is ridiculous these are not bright
people what are they doing
bill maher one of the most prominent
liberal voices said this is bad but it
was all the right wing now you know what
i'm offended by
she doesn't give bill maher any of the
credit and she gives it all to you yeah
she gives it to the best money fair she
claims that the post millennial was part
of this uh campaign to take down the
disinformation governance board um and
you know perhaps we were perhaps we
should take some credit for that was she
knocking on your door
uh no she she um she wasn't actually
she's never reached out to us she
blocked me on twitter i found that out
one time when i
reached out to her for a comment about
how she had doxed libs of tick tock for
no apparent reason and she and she
blocked me on twitter is completely
unreasonable all i did was put up a
billboard in times square saying that
she docks libs of tick tock and then she
blocked me shameless are you blocked by
taylor swift
yeah well i'm on a lot of those what's
what's interesting though is that she's
claiming that we dug up
nina jankowicz's past social media posts
and published articles to generate
controversy it was not to generate
controversy it was to expose exactly who
was the minister of truth who was
running this bogus organization who was
running this operation to expose who it
was that the biden administration
thought it was worthwhile to put in
charge of something this serious someone
who had spread disinformation themselves
someone who had you know essentially
called for censorship um and someone who
clearly should not be trusted to give
accurate or truthful information it is
extremely ironic because jack pasobic
just found jankowicz's early tweets and
released them and it's ironic because
that's the first thing taylor lorenz
does when she tries to make a hit piece
on somebody they just look up their old
tweets so this is what glenn greenwald
pointed out he said according to taylor
lorenz you are not allowed to dig into
the private information of high-ranking
homeland security officials
but it's okay to go after an anonymous
person who has bad ideas no exactly like
when did the role of journalists become
being tattletails on your average person
like someone on twitter said something i
don't like exactly when that happened
almost always hasn't it that happened
but like the average person
it happened with me too it happened with
me too because that was the first time
when it was acceptable to just start
telling tales out of school about
somebody's bad date
i think i think i view journalists like
mini-me like
dr evil is the government and mini-me is
just like you know
well i mean you made this point that's
always what they've done i agree with
you that it's it's always been very much
corrupt i mean the mainstream media in
this country has been has been a
disaster for a lot longer than people
realize but it's the going after like
everyday average random people thing
which is is very strange and yeah
they're they're
there are creepy weirdo authoritarians
running all of most of our institutions
when you look at the supreme court leaks
like these crackpots
these these people are in everything
they they have no uh regard for um
for tradition or culture and i'm not
saying all tradition all culture i'm
saying they have no regard for community
they have no regard for any kind of
norms respect they have i i imagine
they have their their moral compass
their their um
why what the the um
moral foundation sorry oh yeah yeah zero
nothing they don't even have care and
fairness it's just literally nothing
they're just confused angry people
well they think that they're doing the
right thing i don't believe that you
don't think that they think they're
doing the right thing i think they think
that they're doing the appropriate thing
by leaking this information i i i think
they're npcs you think taylor lorenz is
an npc i no oh no no i think taylor
lorenz is the perfect example of a shot
of a modern shock jock
i i think you know based on
conversations i've had with people in
the industry
it's it seems to me it's my opinion
that um
she was hired specifically to generate
outrage and controversy by writing shock
content that is bordering on defamation
the goal being why are we talking about
the washington post now because she
writes something that's a clear opinion
not labeled his opinion knowing it'll
it'll it'll anger a lot of people she
accuses only the right ignores bill
maher which will clearly
the right will be like hey you can't say
like that's not true and you're wrong
and then shows will produce segments
where we'll talk about her it will
generate earned press and that's what
they want
so
i've i've had some conversations
i'm trying to get better confirmation
but my understanding is that the people
at the post are well aware of it that
there are veteran journalists who throw
up in their mouths a little bit every
day because they they're sickened by
what the paper has become because they
know she was brought on specifically as
a shock jock as a culture warrior shock
jock to generate scandal and that's her
thing well and she does and then she
goes on tv and cries about it when
people don't like what she writes for
better or worse i think reporting's
always had this issue where people have
been activists but the more i get
involved and the more i pay attention to
the news the more i realize that it's
almost everybody that's an activist
reporter nowadays it's fine it's hard to
find anybody who isn't really just
trying to back up their priors this is
extremely true with taylor ends but
she's not the only one
no definitely not definitely not i mean
i i've probably brought him up a million
times on this show but we talk a bit
about walter durant every now and again
i mean this is uh
this is very early stuff we're going
back to what the 30s here and the fact
that he was covering up the soviet
genocide because he was himself a
communist and won a pulitzer for it and
they're winning pulitzer's for fake news
to this day i don't think they rescinded
that pulse they did not receive that
that's what it was they didn't rescind
it either which is
insane we got we we've talked about
doing our own journalistic award
ceremony to like counter the pulitzers
i would not call it that that's a
terrible name
um but we would we would call it
something
maybe like the uh
the the truth award that's great
branding like if you call your social
network truth so yeah that's what trump
would call it
i don't think you should call it that no
i think it's a terrible idea a lot of
people he's actually trademarked the
word
yeah people someone pointed out i saw
tweet they're like why didn't he call it
kaffifi like everybody's clever would
have been like download the kaffi app
and everybody would want it oh that's
true trump's coffee app and you need a
weird name but it's like truth and then
you like post truths i hate that i hate
posting truth there's a disinformation
you post anything that's not true you're
kicked off the website like that's right
i'm gonna re-truth ah just know the
truth terrible that actually sounds uh
that sounds like something the
disinformation governance board would do
they would re-truth i think the uh the
institutions are in decay i think that
the culture war is split between those
and the know and those who are not in
the know it has nothing to do with your
with your political positions because i
think everyone here has varying
political positions we all disagree with
each other on because we've had these
conversations before to a great degree
including foreign war or abortion but we
all agree on
basically what's the fact and so
if that's what unites this table and the
people watching we're like okay what's
true and what's not true what can be
verified what's not verified and then
the other side of the culture war are
people who have no idea the democrats
tried to uh create make a legal path
towards third trimester or you know late
term abortions well they did it's right
there in the but they didn't read the
book i mean i'm sorry they didn't read
the bill oh just right there i read the
bill
but that's exactly it so
if
if i
read the bill and i'm like that's what
it says why does it say that and then we
have a liberal progressive on the show
who are like no no no it's like did you
read the bill no you have to read the
bill that was like the parental rights
and education bill no one read that bill
either and so you had a bunch of people
coming out including mark hamill just
being like yay gay and it's like what
are you doing and it's like no one is
prohibited from saying that children
don't teach them about weird sex acts
it's cool it it literally when they were
all screaming gay over and over again
i'm like imagine being in a daycare and
all the kids are yelling nina and nina
and you're like kids be quiet kids stop
yelling that i oh and they're all going
need an eater and they won't they won't
stop that's what it is yes they're all
yelling something and you're like why
are you yelling this
some kid goes hey if you yell neither
neater they're gonna get us ice cream so
they'll start screaming and you're like
i'm not gonna do that that's not
children yes they don't know what
they're talking about they're too
arrogant to actually read it
they believe this the psychotic
ramblings of people like taylor lorenz
and then we have to deal with the
problems when they go and vote for
nonsensical garbage yes
like children suddenly believing that
they are actually the opposite sex just
because they came up with it randomly
it's crazy because you want to wear
towels here and these larger narratives
almost doesn't matter it doesn't matter
what the bill says as long as you're
allowed to run on it and are able to run
on it as like the don't say gay bill
that's the only thing that people do and
that was disinformation that was
disinformation and it was repeated by
the white house over and over again it
was repeated in the briefing room you
know it's disinformation that joe biden
says that the you know best course
forward is gender affirmation telling
parents to affirm their children and it
will save their lives that's
disinformation
this white house consistently spreads
falsehoods and claims that it's true
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you